好歡迎收看理財大人秀的標股在線等的單元
也是大家非常喜歡的技術線型教學的單元
最近喔 台股變得很奇妙喔
怎麼說呢
因為我們的指數雖然這兩天有回檔喔
可是一直在萬八高檔一直震盪
大盤非常高
可是很多的中小型肋骨
跌得非常低
低到怎麼樣
低到堪稱是地板股
這時候你內心就會很糾結 很矛盾
我很想剪喔
它到底是不是落底了呢
但是如果大盤今天
好成萬八又修正的話
它會不會從地板變成18層地獄
每個人都充滿了問號
想剪便宜又很害怕
所以今天朱老師
要來治療這個宜南雜症
朱老師會幫大家去篩
什麼樣的股票符合地板股
不是躺在那兒你都能剪
要有些訊號出現
你減他的時候
安全還有大盤回落的時候
他可能相對抗跌
這邊請教朱老師
我也覺得很掙扎很痛苦
看到指數這麼高
很多股票跌得這麼慘
想去減
但是如果今天大盤回檔呢
我的股票可能200已經跌到100了
會不會100又跌到50
我就很擔心
所以到底怎麼樣避免
再來是以你的標準
現在真的有很多地板股嗎
對
好 我們來看一下
其實我做股票的 我個人來講說
大盤不管怎麼漲
或者我手上的股票再做哪些股票
那我都還是隨時會去找地板股
隨時 對
就說我手上已經有股票再做了
但是我還是會觀察
哪些類股已經跌到低檔了
不管1萬5萬6萬7萬8 都有對不對
因為這些股票未來可能就會有大波段
因為它在底部 它在低檔 對不對
所以我們現在強的你去做
但是現在弱的是你未來的
好的標的
因為他現在很弱
你未來他就會變成一個
很大的上漲空間的股票
也就是我常常跟學生講說
你要自己會找股票
因為你在底部地板股
找到的股票
如果有一天他是完成了
這個地板完成了
開始往上發動了
那各位想一想
他開始發動
比如說連長三天
是不是市場上很多人就會討論它
那這樣市場一討論熱度一來的話
全市場都在幫你抬腳
就會跟來
因為你是在下面就做了
就已經跟著在做了
那這時候這支股票
如果又有基本面
產業又很好
或者是它的景氣循環又來了
那它可能就有一大波的獲利空間
所以隨時
所以現在的股票你當然很重要
因為你手上要注意它漲跌
但是如果有打到低檔
在整理的股票也是一個
我們講鎖股
你就要找來放在這個地方
以後你就是你賺錢的一個商品
有耶 我現在清單一脫拉褲
看有沒有符合朱老師講的
對 我們一個股票跌到低檔
它有幾個原因
一個是它前面漲太多了
所以主力這個做完了
這支股票要一直跌回來
跌到把一些籌碼
這些都跌光了
對閃 閃褲都離開了
這時候主力才願意
再來做這支股票
那第二個就是說
他跌到低檔
為什麼又不跌了
一般來說
他就是跌到
這家公司的價值區了
每家公司總有
他的一個基本價值
防守線 對
你總不 除非他是一家
這個培銜的公司
對 如果是正常好的公司的話
你在這個價位
你去看一下他的基本面
假如他基本面
比如說一連賺個兩塊三塊
那現在股價也跌到二十塊三十塊
對不對
這個本益比也不到十倍了嘛
何況他前面也漲過很大一段
所以這個修正應該就差不多
所以那個基本面
你去顧慮了之下
再來就要看技術面
就像趙華講
有可能還會跌對不對
那這就看技術面了
如果它有這些訊號
基本上代表有人來了
有人進來買了
那這樣子它就不容易跌
所以第一個 低檔要爆一個大量
低檔爆大量的意思就是說
這裡有很多人買
但重點還有後面
就不可以再破低了
這麼多人買了
結果這支股下就沒有再創低價了
所以你心裡應該就比較踏實了
就不會怕說是不是還要再疊
因為這麼多人買在這邊啊
都沒有疊嘛
如果要疊這些人都慘了
這些人全部都被套牢
所以第二個後面
就是他不會再破滴了
那第三個
還要經過一段盤整
因為你疊到這個地方
所有的我們講這個
趨勢啊 架構啊
全部都破壞的嘛
都是空頭嘛
均線也是空頭嘛
所以他一定還要一段時間
去做一個整理
所以你在第一檔看到爆大量的股票
不要很快就去碰它
因為它後面還要時間去整理
而且它整理也會幫你證明
這個地方確實是地板了
反覆測定
它一直在測嘛
這你真的是地板了
它就是跌不下去
甚至於每一次到這裡
你還再去爆大量
一跌到這個地板就有人會買
那就代表有人在撐著
撐著這一支股票
那現在就等它整理完了
後面就是我們再去追蹤鎖骨
那這個整理有的會
慢一點的可能一個月
有的會兩個月 三個月
我們也看過整理很久半年左右
所以我就講這些不是說
現在就去做它
是
你現在先去做排面上很強的股票
然後這個你就擺在邊上
讓它去整理
那也許你找個三五支
其中有一兩隻
就整理到一個多月就供了嘛
那你就可以開始做它了
所以這些訊號如果出來的話
你都可以去鎖股
尤其是已經整理一段時間了
你就可以檢查前面這些條件有沒有
對不對 那如果整理了一段時間
前面又有這些條件
那這個股票也許距離發動的時間
就不遠了
你很快大概就可以
可以抓到一支股票
那符合這個股票
我們來看一下這些
這幾檔股票有沒有符合
我們先看潤太權
我們剛剛講第一個
跌得很深要放個大量
各位你看有沒有
連續四五天都是大量
這個大量的之後
股價就一路就墊高
但是他也沒標
可是這個大量就是沒跌破
對不對
第二個是不是把均線要做好
所以他一定要有一個時間去整理
不然這邊的均線不好
那這邊高點沒過
所以這是空頭
這邊是空頭
那你現在要鎖地板股
就是要在下面爆亮
然後股價墊高
均線整理
看起來這一根要發動就有機會了
像這種股票我們就去鎖到
鎖股觀察
那當然我剛剛有講他的價值區
那你也可以去查一下
潤太泉的基本面怎麼樣
它去年配股配五塊
今年也不會少於這個
所以基本上這個
也有基本面 也有技術面
這支股票各位就去鎖一下
好 一百塊配五塊
資費率五趴
那它五塊不是洗腰
它四塊是泉
它也配股票配面
那四塊的股泉就很高了
非常高
好 那這一支股票各位
也可以去注意一下
可是朱老師
他就是因為疫情概念
沒錯 現在沒那麼Hung了
為什麼會別這麼深
對 但是他還是有他的價值區
他其實有基本面
Hung的時候會供到車
對 那現在才叫地板嘛
對啊 至少回到他自己的獲利
對 在他公司來
基本的獲利
他的價值就在這嘛
那個時候因為有疫情
所以哇 對不對
從八十標了一倍
多漲了一倍嘛
那還有不要忘了
去年疫情他賺很多錢
所以他今年要配給你
又要發股利
他又要發股利
而股價又回到他的價值區
對不對
就算不發股利
這也是合理的價錢
第二個有
底部看到爆出量來了
然後也爆了量了
但現在在整理均線
這個也整理了一個多月
12月嘛 一個多月嘛
那有可能在過年以後
再整理整理就容易就會發動了
所以這個股票我們為什麼說
你擺在邊上 你也不用擔心
因為你沒有買嘛
你發動才會買嘛
那如果存股先存一點可以嗎
可以 那就要試單
有直立率嘛 又有基本面嘛
你可以買一部分
發動的時候再多買一點
又可以賺價差 又可以賺股息
那你如果像剛才那個都在整理嘛
那跌破了你就不買了嘛
所以你也不要擔心說
那再跌怎麼辦
因為他還沒有完成嘛
等到我們後面那一段
他完成了你就可以買了
所以這是我們去追蹤他的
那股票很多股票都
高檔都回來了嘛
那他在低檔已經開始打底了
所以他會領先那些下跌的股票
要比較快
像很多股票下跌
還沒有整理 也沒有爆亮
所以你應該要盯到這種
很快就會發動
那朱老師有特別強調
因為南地在沒有大噴之前
骨魚是把它納入一個價值存股
所以他現在已經回到價值存股的方向
如果以後再噴的話也不會錯過
至少你買在低檔
然後人家也會看
這支股票這麼強
然後又配息那麼高
市場都會幫你抬
這個不用講 市長一定會來追這些標的
其實包括投信也一樣
你看很多投信為什麼買的股票
你現在看不懂
奇怪 這股票也沒漲
其實他們在佈局
他們也是看未來在佈局
所以我們也是在地板股上去找未來
未來的空間
另外就是地板股已經反轉向上
要發動了
那這個你就要把握了
這很重要
這個就要把握了
我要買在其中一點
而且這個把握
如果你在前面就有鎖地板骨的
剛才那些條件的
那應該第一根你就抓到了
因為這個在你手上的名單
是不是
你不能說你手上名單
結果今天長你都不知道
發動了還沒注意
你就還不知道
然後又在問怎麼長三天了
老才去追 不行不行
其實也沒關係 長三天就等回來
因為他才剛發動
是
好 那這個就是剛才我們講的
那些條件 底部有大量
然後骨架沒有再疊
然後整理最後
還要加上趨勢要完成
也就是要有一個大量HK
把在整理的高點要突破
這個高點一突破
這個底部就完成
那第二個他整理了半天
就是因為均線嘛
所以再檢查一下
均線是不是也做好了
均線也有三線多排或四線多排
那如果是三線多排
就注意上面的這個季線
那你可能只能做一個短多
最後它一定要有個大量紅K
這你有個大量紅K 實體棒
那你看到了你就知道
你所鎖到的股票
終於是你的
你當初研判的方向
因為它往上走 它沒有往下跌
那這時候你就要變成要敢做了
要勇敢的做
因為機會來了
你又擔心這個擔心那個
這個股價好像很高啦對不對
對 因為對趙桓來說
我知道一般觀眾的想法
我都已經這樣突破上去了
我為什麼不在那個最低點
最低點就減呢
那個是
搞不好一差已經十幾趴了
這叫事後論
你今天突破了
你才知道這是最低點
那如果往下跌
這個不是最低點
也是啦 對不對
大家一定要確認很重要
很多都是 標股也是
你回頭才知道
哎呀 這個地方我買多好
那是你事後看它漲了
對
那如果跌下來你就不會這樣講
哎呀 幸好那時候沒買
對 對 對
所以其實這是事後論
我們都是事前準備
事後來驗證
它確實往上走
然後我們在這買
你在這買有底部嘛
有成交量嘛 有均線架構
所以你才容易漲 你才容易成功
那這個就是我們已經反轉的股票
那這時候當然你就要開始
釘到這支股票操作了
因為做短也有可能要進出進出的
做長捏要看它不要破壞
對不對 做長線也是要每天守著
因為這個我的長線都沒有改變
那你就繼續做
何況我們剛才在鎖股的時候
這支股票的基本面也已經考慮過了
對不對 我們已經考慮
這個它的底部價值區大概在這
所以你到後面做基本上
你應該不要去擔心公司了
對不對 你就擔心你的股價的
技術面的這個進出去做獲利
好 比如說我們來看這支股票
有沒有符合我們剛剛講的
已經完成了
那那個突破的紅K
有沒有說一定要大紅K
有時候紅K一滴滴而已
越大越好 越大越好
越大越強
你看今天供那麼多人來搶
表示這支股票很熱門
我們看這支股票
第一個這裡有爆大量
這裡有爆大量對不對
第二個股價在這裡就沒有再跌破了
那第三個我們剛剛講
這個均線要做好
均線做好了喔
第四個要有一個大量紅可以突破
那你看
我們不可能買在這嘛對不對
都希望是這樣但不可能
都可能 這叫事後論
你買到這 現在不是一樣跌回來嗎
對不對 因為你還有很多東西沒有做好
因為這個還有一個季線
那現在這個都做好了
好了 那這一支
反而變成一個底部剛剛長的股票
對不對 你可以自己去看
是不是 底部剛剛長的股票
那你就沿著技術面去操作就好了
這個就是一個範例 就是多頭完成的
好 那我們來看這個
這支股票也是一樣
好
是不是也是跌了非常久的股票
我們在這個地方看到了
這裡有爆一次大量15塊
後面就沒有再跌破15塊
那這個也沒有跌破
那現在股價開始了
底底高 底底高 底底高
大量很大的話
大量紅K突破 均線完成
也是我們剛剛的條件
第一個多頭確認
第二個均線完成
第三個大量紅K
然後就拉上來開始走
那這支股票也是
如果你在底部縮股
現在它也完成了
也可以開始追著它去做
好 朱老師
像他這個很厲害
他最低點有一根大量
所以我們也可以觀察一下對不對
代表這個真的是很多內行人
在最低點感接這麼大量
甚至我們可以搭配去看一下籌碼
是誰在買 可以
那籌碼如果沒走
沒錯 加碼那也是一個指標
如果在低點的籌碼是主力的
或者是三大法人的
那當然對你來說就比較安定
你看他們外資投信都在賣
而且最重要他也沒跌破
這一點很重要
那在這我也跟大家講
第一次你看到爆大量
後面一定要很長的時間
只是這是一個指跌的訊號
這邊大概不會再跌了
但是它不一定就會飆
所以後面你看這個就
11月 12月 就兩個多月
然後再放大量
然後才開始來
所以我們就是去等
因為我們股票很多
這些沒有發動的你就擺的
355檔
有一檔先發動就先做
而且4000這支股票
你都已經研究過了
所以它只要一發動就進場
都可以馬上立刻就可以去買
對不對
那朱老師有特別強調
這些股票基本面
我們至少都查過了有一定的基礎
可是我們有沒有可能
從技術現行上面來看得出來
這隻我到底要抱多久
就是等於我出場點怎麼判斷
對
好 那完成了之後的股票
有的只能夠先做一個短線
你只能夠先短線
大體這麼久我只能做短線
那有的你可以去做長線
那這個標準怎麼看
我們來看一下
如果你的技術面還是一個剛才我們講的
哇 第一檔爆了一根大量
對
你好興奮喔
第二天就漲 你又想買 不要忘了
這個是你在搶反彈
哦 他的形態還是空頭
對 對 對 他是空頭
你要去搶反彈可以
大概因為你都知道嘛
彈上去就是有個月線
大概你就做到月線
那個月線就是你短線的目標
因為它形態趨勢都還沒有完成
那你搶個短線就是做一個短線
你不能報的
因為它趨勢還是公統
雖然我們剛剛講說
下來也沒有再跌破
可是你一報要報三個月
要報兩個月
就沒有意思了對不對
你又沒賺錢還報兩個月
就沒有意思
所以如果你是搶反彈
一定是做短線
雖然它到地板
也有爆亮了
但是它彈完了
還要整理
我們剛剛講的條件
你就不要去做
不要再去報了
那如果我的股票完成多頭
多頭已經完成了
但是要去檢查一下
我的均線是三線還是四線
如果你是三線多排
那一定還有一個季線在上面
或者季線還在往下走
所以這時候你也只能夠做到季線
做到季線
如果他不長了
有的時候會過季線
但是八成九成過了都會拉回
過了以後你拉回還是要賣
就先做一趟短的
如果它回來之後
季線也做好了
那你就可以開始做長
就開始
你就開始規劃做長線
大盤整區大概就只能做短線
因為它上面壓力很重
你在壓力地方賣一趟回來再接
所以上到上景線
黑黑你就先賣一趟
因為圖打開你就是知道嘛
上面有一個很大的壓力
你就做做短線
因為畢竟它可能已經疊很久了
才會到地板嘛
所以季線都會壓在上面
對如果條件沒有很好
沒有像剛才我們就做短線
那我們看這支國票
是不是又爆一個大量
這支我真的是
我真的覺得它很貴
可是如果你想去空它
被咖包 他就咖包1300多塊錢
回檔又不敢碰他了
現在變地板股了
你看回檔是不是爆一個超大量
真的耶 好聰明喔
昨天還跌停板耶
今天怎麼會這麼多人來買
他的股信真的很難注目
你有沒有覺得很奇怪
跌停板怎麼有人敢買
超聰明的 好厲害
而且第二天開凡是跌停
就開始有人來了
聽說他買了以後
一直到今天都沒有破滴
很厲害 這裡還殺一根
所以是買的人也沒有賺到什麼錢
當然
因為主力
他會可以在下面去
去整理兩三個月
他可以等
他不急
他有錢
對
因為他要把市場一些籌碼洗掉
洗乾淨
而且他要賺也不是賺5%
沒錯
對不對
五成
對 所以他去整理兩個月
沒關係
但是我們去觀察
你如果今天轉牆了
大家看是不是有個季線壓在這
對不對 這個季線還向下
所以你不管怎麼樣
你說這個好像有撐了對不對
但是都不要忘了
你這你的空間很小
如果沒有空間你就不要做了
因為你做一個短線也賺不到什麼錢
那就讓他去打底
就是因為他現在就在整理月線
要等季線嘛
所以這個還要一段時間
對不對 因為季線還要下來
那最後其實我們也常講
你要變多頭嘛
所以你在這裡畫一條線
這個地方突破我們再來買
突破到這裡也有兩三層
你再來介入
這就是上面有季線做短多
你只能做短多不能做短多
短多到季線也有一小段啦
對
試試看
那第二個這個是有壓力
LED的異光
這個軍線不是做好了嗎
對不對
而且你看這根是不是大量紅K
大量紅K多頭
對 那你可以做
做到哪裡 做到這
因為這裡有壓力
對啊 這根真的好醜喔
這邊有壓
那換句話講
你沒有在第一時間買的你就不要動
就不要動
因為壓力就在上方
你買的大概可以賺到這
你自己算嘛
大概54塊可以賺到60塊
也可以啦
對 大概一成
那如果你運氣好
它這邊爆亮把它突破
那你可能就賺多一點
空手就等下一次回來了
你不要再壓力這邊
等它再一次突破
壓力會變滿一點
所以我們在進場就看一下
我這個大概只能做短線
那你就是短線不長
你就先獲利一下
短線不長就趕快獲利
這兩檔是只能做短的
會遇到前高或是極限
那這一支就可以考慮做長線
哪邊不一樣
多頭完成了對不對
第二個 這個季線有完成了
這次四線多排
那第三個當然
所以你有放過大量
這邊都有大量
那這個你就可以去規劃一下
因為這個壓力已經過了
再來在這裡
這個大量在這
你就稍微的規劃
我就報長一點
不一定說
怎麼一下子疊我就賣了
你就沿著十軍或二十軍去守
這樣子你就會報到
一個比較長的波段
好
所以朱老師有提醒大家
不管現在是萬一萬二萬三萬四還是萬八
永遠都有地板骨喔
永遠喔
可是地板骨你要等它發動的時間
否則你可能會
喔你的字經會鎖在那邊
非常非常久
所以今天有來教你
怎麼抓到發動點
可是發動之後又麻煩了
有人只能坐短
有人只能坐長
所以呢建議大家呢
等一下來收看我們的榮耀班
朱老師幫您先篩好了一些
比較容易做到長線的標的
我們來鎖骨觀察
好好的學習了
好 所以我們要來請教朱老師了
我們在公開的版本有特別提到
有些股票
它的型態比較好
地板之後
就可以慢慢做長線波段了
我想大家比較習慣這樣的類型
因為轉進轉出很多人
手腳一慢又被套牢了
所以到底我們要怎麼樣
可以做到大波段
好 那我們講了這些技術分析了
對不對
那總要怎麼樣
總要來試驗一下嘛
試驗一下
對對 找一下有沒有比較地板的股票
好
股價低
然後風險就比較小嘛
對不對
然後你試試看